start kind of having to do some some
introspective you know really look at
yourself
and boy that guy was right i mean i now
i read that article i'm like
yeah yeah definitely definitely
narcissist definitely trying to prove
something definitely thinks he's smarter
than everybody else
definitely arrogant you know i mean like
i'm going through and i'm like
yeah absolutely absolutely i mean he
stopped just shy of saying scumbag
and i'm so i'll push the envelope and
say
scumbag he could have added scumbag
all right matthew matthew where'd you
grow up where you from originally
i'm from tampa florida and tell me about
your family you had both your parents
when you were a kid
yes yes i had uh yeah my mom and my dad
good childhood um
you know it's it was uh you know i i had
a i had a learning disability
so uh basically i had
i had uh two brothers two brothers
i had two sisters one brother my mother
wasn't supposed to be able to have
children
when she was 40 years old she went in
for a hysterectomy
and found out she was pregnant and
actually then i was born
but i had a learning disability which i
struggled with
and so as a result uh my father was an
alcoholic
and i i don't think i really measured up
to what he wanted in a in a son
i know my brother didn't so this is a
lot of uh
a lot of disappointment a lot of um what
you would call a
i don't say mental abuse you know i hate
to complain about it because
i've met guys that have serious abuse
you know being basically beaten and
tortured or sexually abused so
i hate to say it wasn't a great
childhood it was
it was a struggle so you know
and uh how far did you go in school
um i eventually got a college degree
like i graduated high school
a school for kids with learning
disabilities
basically when i graduated i think i
probably read at a third or fourth grade
level
and then i went on to college but i got
a degree in fine arts
so there wasn't a lot of reading and i
had a
registered learning disability so i was
able to take tests on time
and you know so i was working i was
always working around that
that particular issue and then
eventually you got into
into what i eventually
you know initially after i graduated
college
i ended up getting my insurance license
and i tried to work as an insurance
adjuster but the
truth is i just i couldn't keep up with
the workload
and eventually i i had i started working
construction jobs
and i ended up with uh dating a girl
that was working for a subprime lender
and that and she told me you know you've
got to do this you're charismatic you
know you're a
natural salesman you would be great so
i went and got my mortgage license and i
went to work for this company called
eagle lending
and uh i actually was uh was a pretty
good
as a as a mortgage broker i mean i
excelled immediately
and started closing loans very quickly
the bulk of which contained some type of
fraud
just because of the industry at the time
like my first loan
when i went to go send it to
underwriting my under my manager
actually
noticed that there was a 30 day late on
a on one of the documents when
the my borrower had been 30 days later
on the rent and my manager told me white
it out
white it out make a copy send it into
underwriting you'll be fine so i did
the loan closed i'll make 3 500 bucks
real quick
next guy that comes in he he made 45 000
a year if he made 55 000 a year he would
have gotten a loan
so you change the number you make a copy
you send it in
and most of the guys that were at there
were doing something and most of them
are saying look
worst case scenario is you know you
might get fired
but you're it but nobody's calling the
the fbi
or don't worry about it it's going to be
fine so very quickly
i think in a combination with my fine
arts degree i got more and more creative
and it got to a point where i mean i was
closing i was like the top
producing broker in the office they then
make me a manager
then the company actually got shut down
and
i started my own company and of course i
within six months to a year i've got 12
guys working for me
around what year i would say this is
around 1999
98.99 so
i ran that company for three or four
years
yeah about 80s 87 88 89 right around
88 no sorry 1998. did i say 88
98. okay 1998 right so about 1998 i
think i started the company
and everyone was doing these kind of
games right well yeah
they were um usually they were you know
they were massaging this massaging this
but i mean i just got to the point where
i was like you know there's no
there's no like
you know fraud is black and white you
know people like oh it's a gray area
it's not a gray area you're either lying
or you're not lying
so if you're going to lie then go all in
you know i mean why not i'm already in
trouble
so i'd make a w-2 or pay stub
before it long as you would get caught
by underwriters or they would catch
thing you'd start to realize what you
needed to do to cover for that
and so i started to realize okay if i
make a fake employer
i have to connect it with a real tax id
number with a real company
but then if they call the real company
they'll figure it out so i need to
register
in the directory that this company
is whatever a dba of that company
working in tampa so they'll call the
tampa number and i can answer the phone
and i can verify the guy's employment
so you get more and more creative and
before you know it i have
fake companies thank bank websites i'm
making bank websites um
i mean i'm just going crazy and
you know so the company did fairly well
the fbi said that the company
they wanted to charge me was somewhere
between like 40 to 50 million in
bankroll i'm sorry in a in bank fraud
for the company
this is later basically what happened
was eventually
someone i knew got caught
and got caught another mortgage company
i'd been closing some of my loans
through
they got caught the owner of the company
had
knew me and she wore a wire on me
and i ended up being indicted
for wire fraud and i pled guilty but
there was no dollar loss
like basically i had lied on an
application so i got three years of
probation
but i couldn't run the mortgage company
anymore you know it seems like in the
industry a lot of games are being played
right
right absolutely but not necessarily to
the extent that i was playing
them so ultimately you know after i
become i get on probation
uh i can't run the mortgage company
anymore that's what part of my probation
was you're not allowed to
own the mortgage company you have to
give up your license so i give up my
license
and instead of doing the right thing and
you know claiming bankruptcy moving into
my parents spare room
you know starting over i decide that i'm
going to take it up a notch
and i'm going to start creating
i'm going to go ahead and run a real
real estate scam
just based on things i learned over the
over the years
so i start making synthetic identities
and i i figure out how to get social
security
to issue social security numbers to
people that don't exist
i would then you know i would then order
secured credit cards in their name which
creates a credit profile i would make
the payments and after about six months
they would have 700 credit scores so now
these guys have 700 credit scores and
i would attach them to employment and
i would then go out and buy properties
in the ybor city
area of tampa florida i bought proper i
would go and buy properties for forty
thousand dollars and fifty thousand
dollars
but i would record the value or the sale
of those properties at
two hundred thousand you know 195
210 to right around 200 and then so
each one of my synthetic identities
would buy like five houses
so that it looks like they own a million
dollars in real estate these are people
that don't exist
even people don't exist i mean i gave
them names the names i actually was a
big
quentin tarantino um fan at the time
and uh pulp fiction had come out but i
remember i loved uh
i'd seen reservoir dogs and so i named
the guys were like uh
lee black michael uh white
uh james i had james red i had william
blue
i had uh brandon green
you could see that you know so i thought
it was cute which by the way
the judge saw no sense of humor in that
at all
he had no sense of humor about it so i
i buy these properties and i buy them
for 40 000 each guy buys about
five properties i record the values
around 200 000. so the whole area shoots
up through
and that way i was able to then turn
around get an appraisal on the property
you know you clean up the outside
it's basically a crack house but you
take 10 grand you clean it up outside it
looks good you get an appraiser to come
in
he uses the comparable sales which are
all my comparable sales
and says you know it's funny it's a
shitty neighborhood
but this house over here went for 200
this one 195 that one for 205. i mean i
think your house is worth 200 000. great
so he gives me an appraisal i go to the
bank i
submit all the paperwork to the bank and
they approve the guy for a loan for 190
000
the loan closes i sign the documents you
know i would just go and show up and i'd
say hey
you know can you give me the documents
i'm going to drive it out to my guy
and because i knew all the title people
they were like sure no problem they'd
give me the documents i'd go sit in the
parking lot and i'd sign the uh
i'd sign the documents i'd come back 30
minutes later give them the documents
they'd cut me a check
you know i just made 100 150 000
on this property and each guy did this
and i'd say on average
each person was worth around half a
million to 600 000.
i'd make the payments and then
eventually i'd make the payments for
three or four months
and then eventually my synthetic
identity my false borrower would have a
tragic
accident and he would stop making his
payments
and so then when the collection agent
started sending letters i would have his
sister
write a letter saying look he was he's
he's in a coma he was in an accident i'd
send a copy of it like a 12-car pile up
and you know he was life-flighted he's
in a coma even if he wakes up the
doctors say it'll never work again
that's it now the collection agencies
they have a reason why
it's why this guy isn't making the
payments so and they don't think fraud
and so they immediately foreclose and
they put the house back on the market
and they sell
they end up losing 150 000 and they just
assume hey
we made a loan the guy didn't pay the
markets you know
it's fickle that's it so i think
uh forbes magazine said that i had taken
the market
in ybor city in that zip code and they
listed as one of the top 20 fastest
growing markets in the nation
and i had taken the median price from 50
000 to 250 000
in about 18 months fbi said i
i'm responsible for 11.5 million dollars
in fraud and i flipped or i
did this with 109 houses i feel like
that's an exaggeration but whatever
nobody cares about my opinion
so eventually what happens
and i'm also on federal probation by the
way
what ends up happening is a friend of
mine who was a sheriff's deputy finds
out
that
sorry someone i know gets caught
they explain they tell um the
authorities what i'm doing
there's a task force is put together
they hand the task force over to the fbi
someone that was on the task force knew
a friend of mine who was a sheriff's
deputy he comes to me and says look they
fbi is coming to arrest you
so i take off on the run
i had about 80 000 in cash because i had
to go immediately almost
so i jump in my car i go to atlanta
i rent a house from someone with the
girl i was dating
we rent the house i then go and satisfy
the loan on the house
this guy had a loan his name was michael
shanahan so i satisfy his loan
so i've rented his house i then assume
his identity
i satisfy the loan i create a fake
satisfaction of mortgage
and i go downtown i satisfy the loan on
the house so now it looks like i michael
shanahan own the house free and clear
i then go to three different hard money
lenders and get each one of them to lend
me 150
000 they lend me roughly 450 000
i close on all those loans
simultaneously i pull out the money
out of several different bank accounts
and i take off again
before the secret service enters the
picture now the secret service is
interested in me
they're chasing me i am number one on
the secret service's most wanted list
so i take off the secret service shows
up they're looking for me and i think
they
they named us like the uh the bonnie and
clyde of uh
bank fraud or mortgage fraud or
something and there's wanted posters you
know
and by this point there's articles
coming out left and right in newspaper
articles
uh there's tv programs and we're on the
news i mean it's
it's you know i realize i realize it's
pretty bad so
i'm not thinking i'm definitely thinking
i want to get caught
and i and i by this point i also have by
the way i've figured out how to get the
dmv
of pretty much any state to issue me a
driver's license
so i've had i want to say it was 20 it's
like 27 or 26
driver's licenses in like seven
different states i've had almost two
dozen passports
all issued by the state department so
i'm traveling
in and out of the country we're going
wherever we want we've got plenty of
money
end up leasing a really great town
condo in charlotte north carolina
and uh i start running a scam in south
carolina
borrow i get someone to own or finance
their house to me
a couple of people and i end up
borrowing like 1.3 million dollars there
and i'm pulling money out of that that
particular scam
it was about halfway through pulling
about maybe five six hundred thousand i
forget how much i think i left six
hundred thousand in the bank anyway
[Music]
to wrap it up is that basically one of
the
one an employee
fig it's difficult look they figured out
what i was doing
bottom line is i figured out what i was
doing i walked into the bank one day
sheriff's two sheriff deputies show up
they handcuff me
and they sit me down in the office and
the detective comes
and he's calling me gary sullivan he's
saying well listen mr sullivan mr
sullivan so i'm thinking they
at first i thought they had me i'm
number one on the secret services most
want unless they got me
but they're calling me mr sullivan so
detective shows up he starts questioning
me
he says look wachovia's head of security
says that you're running something
called a shotgun scam
they think you're committing a fraud
blah blah blah and i'm like what
what are you talking about you know so
they get him on the phone and i
argue with him and the detective and i
convince them
i convince the detective that
maybe the bank loan officers did
something wrong but i certainly didn't
so what ends up happening is he ends up
taking me downtown he lets me fill out a
police report
and then he lets me leave
so i take off of course
wachovias had his securities furious of
course the fbi secret service show up a
couple days later they're
livid you let this guy go i end up
end up basically ditch the girl that i'm
with
and then i almost get caught by the u.s
marshals in a starbucks
um because i'd gone back to my old
apartment to get a car
that was horrible i called the fbi
trying to turn myself in negotiated
turn myself in that doesn't work out
these guys want to give me like seven
years for just tampa
i'm sure they want another seven years
for what i've already done on the run
but it doesn't work out so i go to
nashville and i start running another
scam
you know because that's what i do so
i you know i i go there i start buying
houses i drive the price up i start the
whole process over again
and you know what happens is
is uh i meet a girl it's always a girl
meet a girl she moves in
i'm doing what i do and she and i
start messing around with another
another girl and this girl comes over a
couple times a week
and at some point where i found out
dateline nbc was going to do
an ar a one-hour special on me i'd
already been in like fortune magazine
bloomberg business week i've been in
probably 50 or 60
articles chicago tribune's doing an art
like a series zombie i mean
you know and but i was okay with that
what i wasn't okay with
was being on national news on a national
tv because
any idiot can watch dateline and
somebody watches dateline and sees my
face and they go hey
you know that's that's carter he lives
down the street he comes in and gets to
starbucks every day or hey he's so
you know who knows so what happens is
we're basically start pulling out money
and i'm gonna leave my plan was planning
on going to australia because if you
showed up in australia with a business
plan
and like a hundred thousand dollars at
that time you weren't a citizen but you
became a permanent resident alien you
could open a business and you could live
there and buy
property so i thought i'll just go there
and retire
so i'm obviously i borrowed another by
3.5 million in nashville
so at this point on the run i've
borrowed like four and a half million
something like that and so i'm about to
take off
and uh my girlfriend ends up confiding
in
this other girl that we're seeing who i
am and she calls the secret service and
turns me in
and bam that's it now i get arrested
and it's not good it's a bad day it was
a bad day
uh nobody's happy with me
nobody the judge the u.s attorney nobody
finds what i did
as being remotely uh
you know um sympathetic or calm
or comical or i mean like the
satisfaction of mortgage i remember i
signed one of the satisfaction of
mortgage and i did
dozens of them and one of them i signed
uh c montgomery burns
which is the aging tycoon in the simpson
the old man that owns the power plant
so you know these are the kinds of
things that being on the run
and being kind of just creative and
comical and
i would do that then when you're
standing in front of the judge
is absolutely not funny i mean nobody's
smiling nobody thinks oh that was kind
of clever
no it's all bad everyone says you're a
smart ass oh god i mean you know and
here's the thing
and i was you know and this is the thing
is that
yeah is that you know the whole time on
the run fortune magazine comes out with
an article i remember reading the
fortune
magazine article and and just being
offended that they'd
they'd spoken with some some
psychiatrists that worked at uh like
john jay college
um for criminology in new york right
criminal justice or something and
he was saying oh he's a con man and he's
narcissistic
and he does he thinks he's smarter than
everybody else he's trying to prove
something trying to prove to everybody
how clever he is and i was thinking
this guy doesn't know me and that's
that's all [ __ ]
that's a lie that's not true but
this is the way eventually like when i
get to prison i start writing guys
stories
and you start kind of having to do some
some introspective you know really look
at yourself
and boy that guy was right i mean i now
i read that article i'm like
yeah yeah definitely definitely
narcissist definitely trying to prove
something
definitely thinks he's smarter than
everybody else definitely arrogant
you know i mean like i'm going through
and i'm like yeah absolutely
absolutely i mean he stopped just shy of
saying scumbag
and i'm so i'll push the envelope and
say
scumbag he could have added scumbag i'm
doing scumbag things
i'm doing scumbag things and expecting
people to be
impressed by me you know you know you're
just like you're
it's like saying everyone should be
impressed by me
i'm really just a pariah living off of
you know society
but you should be impressed by me
because look at this clever little thing
i did i mean it's just
it was just uh you know just pure
arrogance
so i end up look i can't go to trial
because i'm guilty i'm extremely guilty
i remember my we we actually had a bond
hearing and i remember
my lawyer goes there's the bond hearing
and she said i said
i'm going to get bond and she went just
no they're not going to give you a bomb
but they have to give you the hearing
and she goes if they gave you bond she
was what would you do i go i'd run
and she goes yeah they're not giving you
a bond um and keep in mind too
on the run i've had a nose job
two hair grafts i had a facelift
like three liposuctions i mean i've i'm
going all
in for the whole you're not gonna
recognize me i'm not gonna get caught
so to basically i end up i plead guilty
because if i went to trial she said they
could stack the charges i could have
gotten 150
154 years same newspaper said something
like
200 something years but that's not true
it was 154 years
not that that would have happened they
probably would have just given me 32
years
you know but
uh i took a plea i got 26 years i
i went to prison um
i mean i'll i will skate over
you know to explain you know that i got
you know my sentence reduced twice i
mean the quick version
is that i you know that i
i actually cooperated because i can't go
to trial
and i can't do 26 years and so i
actually cooperated but the cooperation
didn't lead to anything
like no one was arrested so it's like
you cooperated
and you don't get anything and the
problem is is you can't force the
government to give you
a reduction out of cooperation it's
completely their discretion
so like i said i cooperate i nothing
occurs from it
i end up one of the things that the
government
asked me to do was they asked me to be
interviewed by dateline because dateline
had done one one hour special now they
were going to do a second one-hour
special
they wanted to interview me so i'm
interviewed by dateline my lawyer had
told me it would be considered
substantial assistance and they would
reduce my sentence for it
so i do it and the night before i'm
going to be sentenced my lawyer says hey
did the interview what are you going to
reduce the sentence for
how much are you going to ask for off
and they say the
u.s attorney was named gail mckenzie and
she
she said we're not going to give him
anything my lawyer goes you said you'd
consider it substantial assistance she
goes
and i did consider it and it's not
i just remember oh my god and i remember
thinking that she
totally conned me she totally just
bamboozled me
and i remember being upset but looking
back on it i think
i mean what did you expect you can't
[ __ ] and moan about it
i mean look at what you were doing you
can't be a scumbag and then be upset
when people do scumbag things to you
so they didn't do i get 26 years i go to
prison
they then come to me and they ask me to
do a tv show called american green
to be interviewed for american greed
they said we will definitely consider
substantial assistance
what choice am i going to have they
won't put it in writing they told my
lawyer i do it
they air it we go back to the u.s
attorney and say look will you reduce
the sentence you did
both these interviews now and she goes
it's just not enough
i'm then asked to write year a couple
years have gone by at this point
i'm contacted by a someone who teaches
continuing education courses
for uh mortgage brokers because they all
have to take them every year one of them
is on ethics and fraud
they ask if i'll teach the course write
the course for them in prison
in prison you go flies up to atlanta
talks to the u.s attorney u.s attorney
sends an email to to my lawyer my lawyer
they have meetings they're absolutely
going to reduce my sentence for it
absolutely 100
so i write the course it's 9 500 words
they're using it all over the country
people are calling my ex-wife telling
telling her
i just took my continuing education
course and the whole thing is on your
husband and you
your ex-husband and he wrote it so it's
being used everywhere
so we go back to the u.s attorney and
say great how much you're going to get
got off
knock a sentence off and she says that's
just not enough
so at this point i'm basically i've got
26 six years and i'm doomed
when you call your lawyer and say what
are we going to do and she starts crying
on the phone
you have an issue this is a problem
so basically it's like look put in for a
two-minute for a two-man cell
join the softball team you're staying
so what ends up happening is i end up
coming across this
bipolar lawyer who's in prison for he's
a rapid cycling bipolar
with he's an access five rapid cycling
bipolar with features of schizophrenia
since he's been a teenager he has
believed that
god is telling him he is preordained to
be emperor of the world
what i love about it is that it doesn't
affect his legal work
so he ends up becoming a venture
capitalist taking over a whole bunch of
companies
and then once he's got about 40 000
employees he starts with holding the tax
payroll taxes he pulls a two million
dollars and he starts trying to he
tries to take over the congo during a
political coup
it's it's it's insane so this is the guy
who's telling me that god is talking to
him and by the way he ultimately gets 22
years and goes to prison now he's with
me
but here's the great thing about him
he's walking guys out the door
he's getting guys sentences cut in half
he's an amazing
lawyer so
i go to him and i tell him what happened
and he says oh
absolutely not i'm like they're not i'm
not going to let that stand and take
care of this
he files a bunch of emotions all the
same lawyers on the street by the way
told me you can't there's nothing
you can do he files some motions
what's called the 2255 and we we go back
and forth the government he convinces
the government to uh
reduce my basically bring me back in
front of the court and
let me talk to the judge they bring me
back they give me a lawyer
i go back we get in front of the judge
the judge knocks seven years off my
sentence
so that's seven years that's pretty good
but i'm only down at 19.
and uh so then what happens is this
i'm back i've got about eight or nine
more years to go because i'd already
been
done like seven years i got another like
nine years to go
with good time whatever so i come back
and uh
i'm walking around the compound with a
guy who is
who is there for stealing a hundred and
no sorry
57 million dollars from churches and
pension funds
he's about i think he's 60.
and we're walking around and he was in
the middle of
actually cooperating against people that
had helped him
in his ponzi scheme and he ends up
telling me
it's a long story but he ends up saying
telling me eventually just says look
he's like i'm afraid they're not going
to reduce my sentence because
i've hidden ponzi scheme funds and i go
but you haven't and he says
i got a little bit of money here and
there now why you would tell me that
knowing the position i'm in and i'm
right knowing i'm ready to cut
anybody's head clean off their body to
get out of [ __ ] prison
i'm just i'm not here for this day i
want out
i don't care about you guys you don't
care about me
so he tells me that and i end up talking
to my lawyer just
i really wasn't even thinking about
doing anything it was like a month later
i'm talking to my lawyer
she was sending me my transcripts
because i was writing i was in the
middle of writing my own book
and in the middle of writing my own book
you know she i needed my transcript so i
call her and i say hey i need my
transcripts and she says okay she's ever
how's everything going i said oh good
she has anything going on
i went like what do you mean it was
weird the way she asked it anything
going on in there i went
no and she has anything you want to talk
to me about i went
no like why would i it was very it
almost felt like
the like she was she knew something and
i went
well you know i said there's something
happened the other day but i don't i
don't think it
means anything i don't think it can help
me in any way i tell her this is what
the guy says she goes well let me look
into it
she makes a phone call next thing you
know
they call me into the office the staff
there calls me into an office
they ask me to talk to a secret service
agent i talk to a secret service agent
it's a long story i end up explaining
what happened to him they come back
they interview the people that he left
the money with they give up the money
it's like half a million dollars and
they end up reindicting him
he ends up getting six more months the
two other people because they turned in
the money right away
they end up getting a probation like one
year probation it's actually one of them
got i think
uh community service regardless
um you know and this is the thing about
that
is that most people won't tell you that
you know what i mean like most people
like 90 some odd like it's like 89 of
criminals cooperate but all of them lie
about it
so you know it is what it is you know
scumbag snitch rat whatever i don't give
a [ __ ]
so did you ever feel any guilt over
informing on an another inmate
no no i didn't i don't feel i don't feel
bad about it at all
and you know that may be i think
criminals the bulk of criminals are you
know sociopaths
one person one percent of society is
sociopathic
one percent of american society is
currently incarcerated
so you have to assume you know and
basically most criminals
are sociopaths i mean if you're gonna if
you're gonna commit crimes and live off
of society
you're probably a sociopath if you're
okay with that so my sociopathic
tendencies
are self-preservation and i'm not that
concerned
with the other guy so the code exists or
it doesn't no
and that's all there is no code the code
is a lie the code is [ __ ]
the code is something that other
criminals tell you about
specifically to get you to not tell on
them
and then they turn around and they steal
when you go to prison they steal all
your [ __ ]
they what they [ __ ] your [ __ ]
girlfriend they talk
[ __ ] about you and then the moment they
get caught they tell on you
i mean it's it's it's a delusion the few
people that
statistically statistically
based on the the uh federal sentencing
commission's uh report which was about
five ten years ago
it's like 89 percent of criminals
cooperate
and some criminals don't cooperate
because they simply don't have the
opportunity
to do so the code is just designed to
protect
whoever needs to be protected of course
it's it's look
el chapo cooperating mayo cooperating
the heads of the cartels cooperating
with with the government how many
mobsters do you know that cooperate
how many you know do you want to name
off every major movie that's out there
that has you know from american gangster
to goodfellas to
all of them cooperated if to survive
they're cooperating now if you want to
be a stand-up guy
and you want to go do 40 years in prison
and have your child raised by someone
else
and have your your ex-wife or or
girlfriend or baby's mama uh be with
another guy
not answer your phone and you want to be
begging for people on the street to send
you money
by all means don't say anything but
here's what bothers me is that
if you're a guy who's willing to sell
drugs commit fraud
rob banks and then get caught
and tell me that you're living by a code
that you have some kind of an ethical
code
the truth is you know that's what helps
you sleep at night
but you're just a scumbag i mean man up
and just say i'm a scumbag and i'm only
in it for me
and maybe i don't want to talk because i
don't want my family to get killed
or i don't want to get killed or i'm
afraid i got caught i'm going to a pen
where they'll kill me if i talk
but the truth is you're not doing it
because you're a good
solid person who's out there committing
crimes and terrorizing decent
citizens with but you've got honor if
you had honor
you'd be working at walmart or you'd be
you'd be working in a hospital or you'd
be doing something
decent with your life but you're not i
mean just man up and say i'm a [ __ ]
scumbag
i'm willing to say it and as a and if
you don't want to that's fine
but i didn't want to do the extra 12
years so like i said i'll sleep like a
baby at night and if i
if i get called a scumbag and a snitch
and a rat and well i can deal with that
because i shaved 12 years off my
sentence
i'm going to survive so what ends up
happening is
they reindict the guy and we go back to
the
go back to the uh i end up having they
don't want to give me anything for it by
the way
they recruit half a million dollars i
actually had something in writing this
time from the u.s attorney saying if you
if you recover any funds or there's any
indictments we will reduce your sentence
nope this time they go what we don't
know what you're talking about
so i actually had the letter they had
sent the secret service agent so i'm
actually send it to the judge and the
judge goes oh hell no what are you guys
doing
and they he gives me a lawyer and i go
back in front of the judge he knocks
five more years off so i basically was
about 18 months away
from being released well prior to that i
had written my own memoir
so i'd written my own memoir and in the
process of that writing that memoir
i'd started interviewing other other uh
inmates and i'd interviewed a guy named
ephraim debaroli
which did you ever see the movie war
dogs
there was a movie called war dog with uh
jonah hill
so i wrote f from debaroli's memoir
which is called once again gun runner
while i was incarcerated
um there when there was a movie that was
made about him
by warner brothers then i ended up
writing another story about a guy
i end up getting a book deal for that
and i get him into rolling stone
magazine
i partnered with a a reporter and i he
gets in rolling stone
and we we sell the film option we option
the film rights for that
so you're writing this story about other
prisoners
what i what i realized is that these
guys life stories have value
but they're not in a position to write
those stories
does that make sense all right i mean
first of all it's hard to write a story
it would be hard difficult for you to
write your own story because the
truth is you just don't see you as you
really are
by reading several books about writing
memoirs about writing true crime
about writing non-fiction i very quickly
realize
that there are certain catalysts in
people's life that affect them
however they can't see it
for instance my father me wanting to
impress my father who has always been
disappointed in me
it's kind of caught not because of him
it's not his fault it's my fault
but i wanted to impress him so bad i was
willing to do anything to be
to appear successful even if it had
meant commit fraud
and for a very short period of time he
thought i was amazing
so you know and i have so many stories
with these guys where they weren't able
to see what had happened or how they
developed over time and became
these commit began committing crimes
so i i because i had kind of gone
through it myself i see those things
and it goes back to the that
psychiatrist you know
it's like i was upset because i felt i
didn't see myself like that but
what eventually you start to realize is
that if enough people call you an
[ __ ]
you're probably an [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying and there's nothing wrong
with that
you know does that make sense like to me
like i know guys that if you said
bro you're so you're really arrogant
they would be furious what do you mean
i'm arrogant what do you mean
they would get upset and that's how i
would have been but the truth is
you're arrogant but i love you you're
amazing
you're a narcissist but it's great
you're
great you know and then that's the thing
i'm clearly i'm i'm narcissistic
and so but it makes me a great
storyteller
you know it also i also feel horrible
for anybody that's a friend of mine
because the whole time they're talking
i am simply waiting for an opportunity
for them
for a lull in the conversation so that i
can shift the conversation back to me
and i realize i have friends that know
this about me
and i'm so lucky because they will stop
me go
we're talking about me give me five more
minutes to finish my story and we're
gonna talk about you for the next 20
minutes
and you know and it's like they're not
mocking me
they realize it's an issue and i
appreciate that they're
telling me this because i can't do it
on my own you know how many times i've
walked away from a conversation
and i've been like you selfish prick
you spent 20 minutes talking to that
person you don't know a [ __ ] thing
about them
you talked about yourself the whole time
you should be ashamed of yourself
and it's constant and it's it's horrible
it's a horrible sensation to not be able
if you know what it's you know what it
probably feels like
i don't know i don't do drugs it
probably feels like what an alcoholic or
a drug addict feels like
it's just this overwhelming compulsion
and as soon as it's over
they go what did i just do they just
don't even know they're doing it
it's just autopilot yeah and i and i you
know and i
and it's horrible because in some ways i
love myself
for that and in some ways i hate myself
for it
so it's a it's a it's an issue but the
awareness of it is is a huge step i know
and every and i've had so many people
say that that yeah but you realize it i
know but that
almost makes it worse because i think
you
you with awareness and a little
discipline you can
you can police yourself and do then do
the opposite of what your nature is
i listen and i'm trying all the time but
you know i slip
constantly yeah well you know i i mean
yeah and that's what bothers me the
worst
in a way that's it's almost worse
because now i'm so conscious of it
that when i can really see it afterwards
i'm so angry at myself that's what my
channel is all about
yeah well you're looking for flawed
people yeah
you hit the jackpot i just happen to be
making it work for
me you know i i was driving with you
you're making money
yeah i'm i'm doing okay i'm doing good
how much stress were you going through
when you were doing all this fraudulent
stuff you know
listen were you sleeping yeah of course
i was taking xanax
you know i'm saying i mean i'm taking
xanax to go to sleep i'm drinking coffee
all day to stay up
i'm kind of not i'm not really looking
over my shoulder
but the anxiety is there i'm having
panic attacks
you know i seem i'm an extremely
confident person so you're making
millions when you're doing this i'm
making millions
but i'm also very unhappy does it you
know does that make sense
what kind of numbers are you making oh i
mean
i mean look i'm i'm
i am responsible for 15 million
specifically for me
in fraud how much money of that was i
still owe 6 million
in restitution but i would say i'm
making
you know there would be one month where
we would rake in you know we break in
two million dollars
another month we'd rake in you know a
hundred thousand the next month you rake
you're raking nothing
then you end up getting a million then
you there have been times
i mean i'm driving a hundred thousand
dollar vehicle because i'm not really a
flashy guy i'm not gonna buy a
lamborghini
but i'm driving a hundred thousand
dollar vehicle i actually have a couple
vehicles
i've got a a great huge house a couple
million dollars in the bank
panic attacks miserable everybody that's
around me is
only around me because i can make them
money
nobody's a friend i have no true friends
uh and i you know and
i went to prison and i think i had the
whole time in prison two panic attacks
and they were really just like
blips like just minor nothing nothing
nothing like the the panic attacks i had
prior to prison
and i never really felt like i was super
under stress but
but i was constantly worried and i
couldn't sleep i sleep like a baby at
night now
i slept like a baby in prison when i
started writing the stories of my fellow
inmates
and publishing books and my life began
to have a purpose that
wasn't illegal and i was accomplishing
something that i loved
it's like it was like
everything changed and when people
started saying to me
you know you know when i stopped saying
well i was i'm locked up for bank fraud
and immediately started justifying
when i started just saying you know i'm
a con man
so what are you here for i'm a con man
just like that and they would be like
what would you do like i stole this much
money and this and that and
bank for all had charges and it got this
much time and that's it
and they would just go oh they're listen
guys don't just don't they just don't do
that
especially con men con men in prison are
justifying everything they did how they
shouldn't be there and they're
they're preparing to get out cover up
everything they've done and start over
and i would talk to these guys they tell
me about oh there's this company called
you know uh reputation.com and they can
bury all the articles and they could do
this and i could change my name or i
could do that and i'm sitting there
going you're working on your next prison
sentence right now you haven't got out
yet
you're coming back because i have a
friend who's actually in there for a
double murder
and super enlightened 20-something years
he's done and his whole thing was
you cannot go to prison and continue to
behave in the same manner that led you
to prison
you cannot leave prison thinking that
way
and not expect to come back and you know
guys oh i'm not going to get caught this
time or i'm not going to commit any
crimes it doesn't matter you're still
acting like a scumbag
you're still a scumbag it's going to
catch up with you you're a reformed con
man
i mean yeah yeah you know this is the
way i look at it if you're you're an
alcoholic
and you stop drinking you're still an
alcoholic
so am i a comment yeah i'm constantly
saying things and doing things you know
i'm constantly and everybody's kind of
manipulative you know everybody
manipulates a little bit
i'm constantly saying things and and i
catch myself a lot more
and now what i tend to do is say oh i
can't promise you this
this is what i like i try and really
explain this is what i hope will happen
i can't promise you that though this is
what i'm gonna do
hopefully it works out and uh
yeah that's uh so yeah i end up
i end up collecting a lot of these guys
stories i write their stories
i ended up leaving prison with a
collection of stories and several books
uh i started while i was in prison i
actually got uh like a publishing deal
and that that publishing deal i really
made very little money on the publishing
deal so
when i got out i just started publishing
self-publishing my books
and you know writing guys stories and
you know
i near get all get all the stories
narrated stick them on youtube so i got
like a youtube channel with all them
narrated
uh because nobody reads it's so sad
um and you know what's so funny too
about prison is that when by the time i
was in prison
i spent the first couple years just
reading and so my third grade fourth
grade reading level
shot way up i'm still a horrible reader
but you know look there's so many things
that prison helped me with
and i'm and i got out and
i make my bills you know pretty much
every month you know make them and then
some a little bit
not doing great not making crazy money
like i was
but i'm absolutely thrilled
and i'm happy and i don't have you know
i'm not
stressed out and i feel so much better
about myself
than i ever did when i was uh you know
when i was out there and i was making
money and everybody thought i was a big
shot and
you know just absolutely not worth it
and the thing worst thing is is that
when you don't have money and someone
tells you that well listen money's not
going to make you happy
you know they don't believe you they
don't believe you and the but the truth
is it's just not going to make you money
i mean
i'm not going to make you happy maybe i
guess if you're like a if you make a
bunch of money and if you made a bunch
of legitimate money and something that
you loved
i could see you being very happy because
those are the happy people you know
the really the happy people are the
people that are just happy with what
they have
like your friend your friend who's
married with two kids and gets to teach
his
his son's little league you know and
can't shut up about his kids
and loves his job and doesn't make a
whole bunch of money
but he's like the happiest guy you've
ever met and then i have buddies who
who make millions of dollars and drive
lamborghinis and they're just
miserable horrible miserable [ __ ] and
moan
all the time have everything going for
them and are absolutely miserable
and i just don't want to be that guy you
know i want to write
i want to get my stories turned into
documentaries
and films and series
and that's what i'm currently you know
that's what i currently do i do that and
i paint
so you know i've done a bunch of youtube
some stuff on youtube
and as a result of that i get a bunch of
guys that have seen my paintings and
they want me to paint paintings for them
um you know and that's and that's great
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
that oh oh man listen you know how many
times i you know people i know
guys that contact me because they've
seen me on youtube kids
everything what should i do should i do
this should i do that should that be
like you know and it's always it always
boils
it's it's real simple now like
everything's so simple now it's like
you find something that you love to do
and you try and be the best at it
and the money will come i'm not saying
do it don't i'm not saying
don't you know you don't want to live in
the street don't be stupid
but if you have to stay in your parents
spare room for a year or two
to get it off the ground stay in your
repair stop trying to keep up with your
buddies
find something that you love and the
money will come
it's a it's a pretty simple you know
it's a pretty simple
model and if you talk to any of these
billionaires
and the people that i've met who
millions of dollars
the guys that are the most happy are the
guys that found something they were
passionate about
and then like honestly my girlfriend i i
she we she works 40 hours a week
and i know that she feels like i never
work
i'm really working 80 hours a week but
because i'm having such a good time
doing it and because all i do is i paint
and i write and i
you see me and i do videos and stuff
like that so to her i'm goofing off
but i'm making tons i'm making tons of
money by making really good money
pretty good money doing i don't even
feel like i don't feel like i've had a
job since i left prison
i really don't because i'm really just
doing what i like to do
and if it never gets better than it is
right now
it's better than it ever was
excellent so matthew thank you so much
for talking with me
sure interesting story it's a great talk
thank you so much i hope i kept it open
that was under
an hour yeah no you did a great job
you're a great storyteller too i
appreciate it yeah that's awesome thank
you
you